that's what's up mamas monkey team go
gwen
ben don't touch my car
there's no beginning there's no end
there's only the eternal now let's go
play some football
hey i'm greg sipes i've been in hundreds
of different television shows but most
people know me as beast boy from teen
titans girl
[Music]
i got into acting as a very small child
i started off in
children's theater and commercial work i
also grew up on the jerky boys and i was
inspired to be a prank caller
my family is a big family i have nine
brothers and sisters
and we drive around the united states in
a camper
at the age of around four or five i
would get on the cb
and i would mess with truck drivers and
my dad goes one day you're gonna do
cartoons and he was right
fast forward to when i was 20 years old
i moved to la
and i landed my first ever voice acting
audition
i never did the voice before my whole
entire life i looked at a picture of
beast boy
out came this voice first time ever and
three months later
i got a call that i got the role of
beast boy
in the animated series teen titans and i
had no clue
how life-changing and how big of a role
this was
teen titans has been the number one show
on cartoon network
for almost 20 years solid
world see right there even that word
warlock so after landing the role of
beast boy
my voice acting career really took off
so far
i've acted in over 1500 tv episodes
i got roles like michelangelo from the
teenage mutant ninja turtles which was a
huge deal for me because i grew up
watching the ninja turtles it was my
favorite cartoon growing up
recently i have a role on ducktales and
ducktales was one of my favorite
cartoons growing up as well so
to play all these roles now and to offer
them to this next generation has been
the most amazing magical experience
one of my favorite things about being a
voice actor
is the creative freedom that i'm given
for every role
i begged and begged and begged for for
years and years i'm like beast boy
he should be singing a a song in the
show
and i have this song called fadeaway and
they wrote
this song into the show
[Music]
i also love having the ability to reach
so many people with positive vibrations
which that's what cartoons are they're
positive vibrations
yeah peace boy that was
beautiful